next question hey David what's the
difference at this point between the
alt-right and just conservative
Republicans this is an important thing
to understand you know back in 2010 when
we had the rise of the Tea Party it was
important to understand what the
differences were between the Tea Party
movement and broader conservative
republicanism as it existed in the style
of you know george w bush or whatever
right now it's important particularly
because donald trump receives a
disproportionate amount of support from
the alt-right to understand the
difference between the alt-right and
broader conservative republicans the
alt-right is more concerned about
cultural issues other than abortion
right so traditional conservative
Republicans still have abortion as
basically the cultural social issue the
alt-right has become very concerned with
things about you know nationalism
non-whites who won't integrate in the
United States immigration in a much more
xenophobe likely in a xenophobic lis
tinged way non-white cultural race
realism we're seeing that is a notable
difference between the alt-right and
traditional conservative Republicans and
this actually links back to Richard
Spencer in many ways I don't want to
make him more prominent than he deserves
but Richard Spencer who I don't remember
if he coined the term all right or
started growing the movement under that
name he's one of the early people and he
on my show said he is a white
nationalist a white separatist he said
it on my program and you have to
understand that to understand one of the
main splits between the alt-right
and broader conservatism traditional
conservatism and this is a really
interesting thing traditional
conservatism is more individualistic in
economic areas deregulate let people do
what they want let businesses do what
they want don't support people with
welfare let them you know as they say
pull themselves up for their from their
bootstraps and determine their own fate
and future free markets that type of
thing and interestingly the alt-right
has a more collect
this component but only in certain areas
specifically along lines of we have to
defend white workers we need to defend
native-born Americans so while the
traditional conservative even if some of
their policies are implicitly
discriminatory on racial lines their
focus is on individualism even if some
people who are in the so-called you know
parts of they have agent identities
there and in the overclass don't do as
well but the alt-right is more open to
the idea of the government getting
involved in collectivist policy assuming
that it is again the defense of white
workers against brown people from other
countries the defense of native-born
Americans people from good countries
instead of [ __ ] countries that type
of thing so that gets us to the race
element yeah I mean the alt-right is
more explicitly racist while many
conservative ideas are racist in their
affect by preserving the status quo and
not dealing with issues in society and I
want to be clear I'm not defending
conservatism I'm pointing out what the
differences are the alt-right is less
concerned with being pro-business for
example as is traditional conservatism
traditional conservatism is more about
perpetuating the status quo an
aristocratic over class while the
alt-right is less overtly concerned with
that they want to perpetuate a sort of
nationalist
native-born over class even if it is not
economically an over class in all cases
there's actually quite a difference
between reaction ISM and conservatism
even though they're often conflated
because there is a lot of overlap in the
United States in practice in the u.s.
much of the conservatism that is in the
mainstream is reactionary but in strict
terms these are actually two different
things the non reactionary conservatism
exists you know in some academic circles
to some degree but not all there are
libertarian with their wings of right
libertarianism that are less reactionary
than the alt-right what makes this more
complicated is that there are not clear
lines and lots of these movements are
super well defined they're often
leaderless the sue they support will
often shift but in some general sense
the alt-right is much more ethno
nationalist and authoritarian while
their traditional conservatives do have
some authoritarian tendencies when it
comes to for example religion and
implementing and enforcing religion but
they are generally less authoritarian
and thus more likely to be disgusted
with Trump's authoritarianism then is
the all right now a lot of overlap even
people who don't consider themselves to
be in the alt-right but say that they
are conservatives can have authoritarian
tendencies or like Trump and that's an
important thing to understand we saw
this manifest a little bit I don't even
want to talk about this but in the
recent groper versus talk a turning
point USA Don jr. thing I won't get into
it now but look that up we have a
segment on it and you can find out a lot
more about it